welcome everyone
i want to say for everyone from the us
hello
anyone of my spanish people here
benvenitos
italian
everyone so thank you
i'm gonna get this started
so
i'm here to talk about how flutter can
change the future of urban communities
and i'm going to do a presentation
basically a project a project based
presentation about
how this can be how this can happen
so who am i
i'm edward thornton
i'm a software developer i've created
apps for companies individuals things
like that
i'm also a best-selling author i grew up
in california in the middle of the
desert and i moved to saint louis when i
was uh
maybe in middle school so
it was kind of a
culture shock growing up like going from
the desert to an urban
environment
but
living here in saint louis has gotten me
involved in several social causes
the
ferguson riots for instance was a major
catalyst that made me want to develop
some of the apps that i've worked on and
i'm going to show you guys one of them
right now
let me bring this up
uh bear with me on any anything that may
like blackouts or anything like that so
kind of new at this
all right so let me pull up this quick
time
and while i'm doing this i want to talk
about how easy flutter is is one of the
main reasons why people use flutter
because of the ease of use so
i'm going to highlight that
momentarily
okay
here is lupe and i want to show you some
of the things that luke has helped out
like during the different process not
just here in saint louis but also around
the world
what i did use in florida was i created
an app in which it allows users to and
strangely it's called loop you know like
i know the strange loop so i had this
before actually this conference but it's
strangely called luke
but i'll give you an example of what
what you can do with luke
i'll make a post about here
first one
now what is what is really made for is
it's made to inform people about how to
you know be safe in their areas and also
how to combat crime and just for safety
issues
so if i was to put
the same
the same
incident
in this area at three times
it would actually highlight on the map
strange loop
i'm gonna give you guys a demonstration
here
and i actually put a lot of different
categories here if you can see just like
different even stuff that probably don't
make no sense but when i was doing it
it all made sense and this is just like
to keep people safe in their communities
and i've used this in several different
communities which i'll show you in a
second
so i just made a post three times now i
can go to the app to the map
and right now there's nothing showing up
but
in one second here
it should populate
but while i'm doing that i want to show
you how people all over the world were
able to benefit from this technology
like recently in nigeria
and if anybody's in from nigeria i just
want to say a cabo mile kabusa
they were they had a whole sars and
police brutality thing a lot of people
took to my app
to um
you know protest and just talk about how
they can
you know like
coordinate everything so i was actually
happy to be a part of that
so let me see
okay
so now as you see
if you look at the map from the three
incidents that i showed
it pretty much highlights it and it
shows the loop of the area to highlight
okay something is going on in this area
some some areas they don't have like
access to like fast police service so
just having something like this like i
put up a category
of a car fire that would really help the
community i'm sorry about that that
would really help a community when it
comes down to uh policing and
self-policing
so let's get back to this i might come
back to loop later
okay
so what is flutter floater is an open
source open source cross-platform
toolkit that helps developers build
native interfaces
now since flutter 2.2 you can now
develop with android ios linux windows
and web
and it's basically helps you by using
one code base to compile to all native
applications
and
that's what flutter is and flutter was
created in 2017
and launched by google a lot of people
found out i was doing the flooded thing
and a lot of people been asking me do i
work for google and the answer is no
[Music]
so
flutter consists of
two important parts
a sdk
which is a collection of tools that help
you develop your applications
this includes this includes
tools to help you compile the code into
the native languages and also a
framework a user interface
library built based on widgets and those
widgets you can put together to create
almost any type of application on
different type of screens
here are the benefits and loopholes of
flutter the
sdk one it has express development
it has so the express development is
more like you can develop really fast
with google i mean really fast with
flutter
and that's what i think why one of the
main reasons why i think it would be
very useful for urban communities
during the fast-paced hustle and bustle
of how people move i think that a
framework that allows you to get the
deployment time cut down
is like very useful
it's flexible and it has an expressive
user interface
the presence of a modern reactor
framework
you have access to native app features
which is something that wasn't really
quite captured in the past by a lot of
different
cross platform frameworks loop it gets
really close to those native features
which makes the apps run more smoothly
on different type of devices and it has
a unified app development which you can
use one code base to change up every
different um
every different device you need
these are widgets so
i'm gonna give you an example
of um
i created something here i created a lot
of things for this so bear with me on
this
this is a
flutter lab when i was trying to run
this at home it was um
taking a long time so i decided to go on
the web
and i created a just a small app i
actually did it this morning so that
could show you how fast that flooder
works
if this wants to cooperate
while this is working here
i'm going to talk more about these
widgets
so with the floater widgets it's more
like the same way widgets have always
been but with flutter you can use those
and compile them together in top of each
other stack them in containers and make
just different type of apps different
types of anything that a screen anywhere
that you can have screen you can use a
flutter
and it helps with that very much
what's going on here
okay
let's see what's going on here
i want to show you guys how to use the
hot reload which is a key feature of
flutter that a lot of people rave about
so
what i did with this i just created a
you know just an app just based off the
speakers in fact
these were the guys that just left here
if anybody caught the the presentation
before this they did a great speech
presentation about client side deep
learning
i did uh some of the speakers before me
here
and uh
i think he speaks a little later and of
course me a man of hour
now i want to show you guys how this uh
hot reload works i'm just going to
change a few things here
so as you see just from just that one
two changes i did
i changed the name and the color which
is that's like pretty much the how
flutter works this is really fast it's
really responsive you can make changes
in the instance and it just really helps
you along when you're trying to see
exactly what you're doing
so let's get back to this
so here's the bulk of the speech
i'm going to talk about
how flutter can change the future of
urban communities
i can go for uh
a lot of different ways one
is the fast development time
two is truly cross-platform three it's
easy to maintain and develop new future
features with flutter four is easy to
adopt to new screen dimensions and five
and important to me when i first started
was that you can use flutter to create
your startup mvps really fast and
quickly
so first we're gonna talk about the fast
deployment time
as i just showed you the hot reload and
just different things of that nature is
one of the biggest advantages of using a
flutter application it's a
cross-platform solution in which you can
get apps out really quick using a single
cold base and a lot of developers love
that especially businesses so when you
want to really get get it going
so the truly cross-platform nature of
flutter
is what makes it very appealing
so let me talk more about that and dive
into that
it has a single code base for every
every platform
it uses completely customizable widgets
so even with
even with the
when you doing the wedges you can
actually customize the widgets to suit
your needs so if you you can have it
like a something that's big you can make
it small it's a lot of different things
you can do with flutter it comes with
great learning resources the flutter
community is very expansive and it's
growing every day
and
it's a lot of people in there to help
you if you need help you can always
reach out it's
facebook groups with over 200 000 people
in it
it provides a great development
experience so when you're developing
with flutter you get the good experience
of having a wide great learning
resources but also many many different
experiences as far as like they have
flutter meetups here in st louis and
also all over the world
it's a low development cost if you're
doing a like let's say a typical thing
where you have to have two or maybe even
three different type of code bases it
runs up the price and you have to hire
more developers or
things like that but with flutter you
can actually just work with maybe one or
two developers and just get the whole
code base going
and it's actually really really suited
for mvps and startups because
of just everything mentioned beforehand
so i'm going to talk about how it's easy
to maintain the new features of flutter
so basically after you
after you've published your app with
flutter it's then you can start working
on trying to promote your app and gain a
user base as opposed to different apps
of the past to where what different
different uh
different thing programs of the past
where you have to definitely
have a major concern about secondary
issues pertaining with bugs and things
like that with flutter it helps you just
keep everything
singular and just be able to move
forward
okay
also
flutter is easy to adapt to different
screens
that's one of my favorite things about
flutter it doesn't matter what type of
screen dimension you have you can have
an iphone you can have a television
screen they making them now with the
windows with the macs with the linux so
whatever screen that you need flutter
actually
conforms to that screen and it actually
conforms right away so
it's easy to do that it's actually with
a touch of a button so that's great to
know that almost any screen that you
have you can upload a flutter even old
screens like i seen someone with a very
old tv putting the flutter app into use
on it so
it's kind of amazing with that by the
way so
in the future
it will be they with the ad with the
release of flutter 2.2 they actually had
put it to where now you can do desktops
and just web apps at first you couldn't
do web apps when i first started
uh you could only do mobile apps now you
can do web apps with the mobile apps and
they all still compile to the same code
base the right now
as far as the support for the web apps
is kind of lackluster but in the future
they're going to be working on that and
i expect it to be really good
okay
lastly i wanted to talk about how you
can use flutter to create your startup
mvps
well i'm not
sure how many people here are interested
in that but when i first started i was
really interested in how flutter helped
me as a person that was you know having
a startup by myself
and uh needed a
just a single code base to work and just
be able to do it myself and flutter
actually helped me out a lot because it
was able to
take take what i had and just you know
get get it out there in time get it out
there running which helped me out a lot
the code works on
all of the diff the big devices
eliminating the need for multiple apps
and devices
also
to note the performance of flutter is on
par with most native apps which makes it
uh
ideal choice when you want to
start up your mvps
the it's also uh let me okay wait a
minute
so
yeah
so i want to do something else here
because i wanted to i'm actually uh
wanted to show you guys how
this could possibly
even quicker than that right because
if that wasn't quick enough
then i want to show you guys this
flutter flow example
i actually created another strange loopy
app this time with a
thing called flutter flow this makes it
even easier and i and i can actually
just
run down a different thing this actually
was just created it was created by some
people in ethiopia i actually wanted
them to you know like do a video so i
can play it here but they told me no so
yeah that didn't work out but
i'm gonna run this real quick to just
show you guys how
when it comes to making mobile apps
flutter is really is really fast it's
really something that just helps out a
lot when just pushing stuff out i've
done plenty apps with flutter
and uh
yeah they all are very
good actually
okay maybe i'm doing this
well
i'm not sure what's going on with this
so yeah but basically i made another app
with flutter and it just using the
flutter flow
uh
framework which actually brings flutter
down even easier so
i actually left a like a flyer on
everyone's seat and i have a bunch of
projects there
this these flutter flow projects are
actually amazing and i actually broke
down how to use the flutter flow
in the book and also just start a bunch
of different other flutter projects
you know stuff like this happens i even
saw bill like not bill gates but i've
seen this happen to steve jobs one so
i don't really feel too bad
yeah i'm gonna just take this off
that's crazy because it actually is like
a really really good tool to use to
learn flutter and to move forward with
flutter
so
i mean in conclusion
i want to just just say that me
personally from my experience using
flutter i really think that it's a great
tool and it it moves like the city moves
it moves fast
it moves responsive
and i could just really see it like
really taking off in different areas
i actually put a map here of where it's
actually taking off at oh okay maybe i
didn't
you got taken off
but it's moving forward in countries
that you probably wouldn't expect like
different countries like brazil puerto
rico
all across africa
and arabia
countries where
you wouldn't really think that people
would be doing using programming
languages and mobile application
frameworks but that's exactly what's
going on so
i really think that
flutter is ideal for urban communities
and moving forward i think that it would
be a great
way to you know to start programming
with beginners
so
thank you appreciate it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you